hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the development and
commercialization of robust circulating
DNA and RNA tests presented by Hestia
melon she's a director within the bio d6
development group I am Marjory tourist
of labyrinth and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational website
menara presented by lab roots lab roots
is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many of your
questions we have time for at the end of
the presentation also please notice that
you'll be viewing the presentation in
the slide window to enlarge the window
just click on the screen icon would hit
it on the lower right if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Hesse Oh Melek I will now turn the
presentation over here
thank you for that introduction and
thank you for the organizers for
inviting bioethics to talk to you today
about one of the tests that we have
developed and commercialized that
specifically is designed to measure DNA
and RNA variants for patients with
non-small-cell lung cancer here are my
disclosures today I would like
essentially for us to be able to take
away a few key points first we would
like to evaluate the relationship
between DD PCR and liquid biopsy second
to understand the process used to create
a DD PCR based test for liquid biopsy
then appreciate droplet digital PCR
technology and how it applies in this
field briefly the outline of the talk
will involve an introduction to the bio
DES X clinical laboratory the Genest rat
test which is specifically the test that
looks for these targeted mutations I
will discuss with you a physician
initiated study that demonstrates the
utility of Genest rat in the community
and then we will use one example from
the Genest rat test the EGFR t7 90m
variant to review the product
development process and the specific
validation work that goes into
commercializing one of these tests into
the clinical laboratory finally I will
come final complete this presentation
with a brief discussion of the horizons
for Bioethics and our partners in liquid
biopsy field bioethics is a fully
integrated molecular diagnostics company
from capabilities from discovery through
commercialization we have a product
development process which has followed
for the development of any new test that
we are going to bring into the clinical
laboratory and this process requires
validation of those tests these things
may sometimes include clinical trials we
have a robust regulatory and quality
system in place which I'll discuss on
the next slide and a reimbursement team
is I'd like to say best in class and
their ability to actually understand how
our tests including the better shot in
the Genest rat test on market are
actually reimbursed by Medicare and
other private pays the barest rat test
is a proteomics test and I won't talk
very much about that in this
presentation because the focus will be
on the Genna Strachan ohmic test a
little bit more detail about the the
crap and clia laboratory in which we run
the Genest rat test so we are certified
by both we also have New York State
class certification for both soluble
tumor markers as well as molecular and
cellular tumor markers for Gemma strap
test we have an ISO certification
it's 1345 and business access from
Monday through Saturday the technologies
that we develop using our both
proteomics based technology and
specifically maldita which is the
technology used to run the barest rat
test and I won't talk more about that
today but the technology that we are
using for a Genest rat to look at
specific variants of interest of DD PCR
this is an overview of how the Genest
rat test fits into the bioethics long
reflex so Genest rat is a test that can
cover the most common mutations driver
mutations and non small cell lung cancer
including EGFR K rats and B rap as well
as Al Qura and Ross in the case where
you have an EGFR positive result many
patients will go on to the targeted
tyrosine kinase inhibitor therapy and in
cases where they become resistant the
Genest rod EGFR t7 90 and the test
becomes relevant as well for additional
targeted therapies in the case where an
EGFR negative or unknown is found that
is where the varus trap proteomics test
becomes a key utility defining a patient
as either good where they will benefit
from cotton based therapy or a poor
where they are less likely to benefit
and
start looking into additional
therapeutic options such as
immunotherapy so why are we focused on
blood and liquid biopsy at biotechs
these are some key advantages of blood
compared to the gold standard which is
tissue biopsy so obviously there is a
minimally invasive nature of blood so
from sample draw to result can be done
in as little as 72 hours and I'll show
you data that represents that whereas on
the tissue side the logistics of getting
tissue results can prolong that timing
to median of about 12 days but it can be
even longer and in addition it is not
minimally invasive in fact up to 25% of
non-small cell lung cancer patients
cannot even get enough tissue to get an
appropriate on molecular diagnostic
results to guide their therapy there is
a potential for serial monitoring as
well because of the non-invasive a
minimally invasive nature of what
testing compared to tissue which is
something that I will show you some data
on later on in the presentation and then
the quantification is is very robust
using PCR and specifically DD PCR or as
many of the gold standard tissue tests
such as IHC give you some oquawka semi
quantitative results
blood and tissue really do kind of
complement each other when you think
about heterogeneity in a tissue you're
sampling a subsection of the tumor
whereas in blood you're getting a more
general idea of what the tumor content
and mutation status might be and in
terms of regulatory approvals tissue is
definitely the gold standard and has
been fda-approved for some time blood is
kind of an up-and-coming technologies
tumors with these different high
sensitivity technologies there is one
test thus far in plasma that is fda
approved that's the rovco best test what
specifically then are we looking at when
we say we're doing a liquid biopsy or a
blood based test for nucleic acid so
we're looking in the plasma of patients
I'm specifically at their DNA and RNA
content and we know that in that DNA and
RNA a subset is going to be directly
from the tumor so we can measure that
tumor derived nucleic acid there's two
different ways to do this we do it by oh
does X pretty well accepted and well
studied in the field I think you would
find that the cell-free DNA
fraction and tumor DNA from that
fraction can be used to measure variance
in NSEL c we're also looking at RNA we
found that RNA is a robust way to get
even more additional information from
the tumor by looking at your patient's
plasma this is a more visual way of
looking at the same same idea so many
other companies are looking for example
at circulating tumor cells which are a
good source of understanding the tumor
here at bioethics we're looking at the
plasma and specifically for DNA we
captured the cell free DNA and in the
case where we're looking for RNA
variants we're looking at multiple
different sources from that plasma
including platelets exosomes and cell
free RNA to dive a little bit deeper
than into what specific variants we are
measuring using the DD PCR technology we
use the cell-free DNA to look for
variance in EGFR Queiroz and iraq
including le I beta are EGFR deletion
19t 790 m and K are three different g12
variants as well as the iraqi 600 e and
then out of the RNA tubes we're looking
for the fusion variants that result from
rearrangements and the those common
genes and NSEL c al cross 1 and r at
these tubes these specialized tubes
which are provided to us by strek are
very important for our tests because
they can be shipped at ambient
temperature and stabilize the nucleic
acid that we're going to analyze
downstream because these tubes can be
shipped at ambient temperature the test
is can be available in many different
types of regions so not only in major
academic centers but also in the
community setting where a reference lab
might not be just next store
and so you can see here on the map of
the United State 44,000 variants have
been tested across the most of the
United States and we're actually also
outside of the United States now we have
checks coming in from Israel and India
as well this is the metrics around the
turnaround time that the Jena
stratocasters in DD PCR can provide to a
physician and this is really one of the
key differentiators I would say from
using this type of testing paradigm so
you're able to get a test result back to
a physician about 82 percent of the time
in 48 hours of receiving the sample in
house and 96 percent of the time in 72
hours so it's quite fast from receiving
the sample to results batches of the
physicians I would like to share with
you now a study that was done actually
blinded to bioethics at the time but it
was presented with lead author being dr.
Boling at is Lac in 2016 so the Brodie
Institute along with four other
Institute's we're looking at the time
two results that they were experiencing
in their NSC LC patients due to the
logistics of tissue biopsy and what they
found was up to 30% of patients at the
community-based academic centers did not
undergo guidance recommended tissue
testing and a patient's that did receive
tissue testing an additional 16% didn't
have a results necessary to make
first-line treatment decisions based on
molecular data the median turnaround
time for tissue was 12 days it could
range up to 54 days for a result in
newly diagnosed patients and was
more dramatic in resistance patients
with a median of 27 days and a maximum
of 146 days for a patient result so this
group decided to measure the impact that
Jena strat could have these kind of
issues they were seeing with tissue it
ran a hundred and seventy nine Jena
strat tests for the study from five
different thoracic oncology programs and
the average time to result was thirty
three hours
ninety-five percent of the result
results were delivered back to the
physicians performing the study in 72
hours and this was also you know
important to note that about 20% of the
patients results that they got that
identified a variant positive result
what did this mean for these clinicians
essentially it demonstrates the fast
turnaround time of the test but also
they noted that it also improved their
ability to intervene earlier and improve
outcomes for their patients specifically
at the Leo Jenkins Center earlier
testing resulted in patients starting
treatment within seven days of their
initial diagnosis so this study really
demonstrates how adoption of a blood
based strategy can really impact the
earlier treatment decisions in the
continuum of care for lung cancer
patients how does it happen in the lab
so this is an example or workflow that
demonstrates the processing that goes on
once the sample has been entered into
the bioethics clinical labs process the
kit is received early in the morning on
the first day by FedEx overnight we
accession that kit and then we split the
tubes depending on whether or not
they're stabilizing RNA or DNA into two
workflows from the DNA extraction we can
measure EGFR chaos and variance while
from the circulating RNA extraction we
are able to look for
um oh for al cross one and rent variance
at that point the RNA is reverse
transcribed and then both templates can
go into droplet digital PCR this is an
example here of the 2d plot that you
might see as a result of DD PCR and this
allows our technical staff to result a
positive or a negative back to the
position again this process working
within 72 hours from receipt of the
sample so getting a little bit more into
detail as to what you might find
as a result to on one of our tests and
you can see an example of a positive for
each one of the different variants that
we're measuring on this slide so
focusing here on the first which is the
EGF bar del e 7 4 6 2 a 7 5 0 mutation
in exon 19 you can see that there is a
gray population of cells or excuse me up
droplets here these droplets are
actually void of any template the green
droplets here are wild-type DNA so DNA
that does not have the e 7 4 6 2 8 7 5 0
mutation and we use those as an internal
quality control from our assay and then
if the patient is positive for that
mutation you will see droplets on the y
axis here in blue and those droplets
indicate that the mutation was present
next before I show you the specific data
that goes into the validation process I
wanted to introduce to you the product
development process that we use here at
bio dezik to ensure that we have a
product that fits the design that is
required and the quality that is
required to be run in the CLIA CAD lab
so the it's a phase gated process that
starts with concept and then moves into
a pilot
once one gets to the pilot phase there
is a checkpoint and we review these data
with the management team to confirm that
the product concept is ready to enter
into a full product development process
the process then starts with product
feasibility goes into verification and
validation transfer and then on market
monitoring all of the phase gates steps
here begin and then end with management
review of the progress again so that we
can maintain the appropriate tests with
the appropriate quality once it's in our
commercialized lab this is an examples
of than what the development process
actually entails we start with
feasibility and this is where the design
of the specific assay that is required
synthesis of the primers and initial
testing with some analytic samples takes
place this is a process that we've
worked very closely with bio-rad to
define and develop new assays in some
cases highly multiplexed assays that
allow us to really get good coverage of
the necessary variants and NSEL see once
we finish with feasibility we move into
the verification and validation phase
where we optimize the different aspects
of the assay and then lock that assay
and perform validation exercises which
could include things like defining the
lower limit of detection of the specific
assay looking at the precision of the
assay and its robustness understanding
the ship stability required for that
assay and then running both normal
healthy donors and clinical samples that
are known positive and negatives to
define sensitivity and specificity
finally in the transfer phase we take
that defined assay and we move it into
our commercial lab we make sure that all
of our personnel are fully trained and
competent so that we can deliver the
appropriate test results to the
physicians
now we'll walk you through
an example specifically EGFR t 790 m of
one of the variants in Jena strat so
just a quick background on t 790 m it
merges as a drug resistance mechanism to
first-line TK is le I did arendelle 19
being two of the most prevalent in n
SCLC there is a drug that has been
approved in t 790 and positive patients
that have become resistant to these
first-line therapies called aspirin and
there is an IBD test the Kovas PG a
permutation test that was originally
designed for FFPE and more recently was
also approved for class
EGFR t 790 and results look something
like this these are the analytic
controls that we run when we r batch
processing clinical samples so you can
see on the left hand side the positive
control which is a horizons
cell line that is known to contain the
t7 India mutation and so you can see
both the green droplets on the x axis
demonstrating presence of wild-type DNA
as well as the EGFR t7 90 a mutation on
the y axis in the blue droplets and then
we also run a no template control as our
negative control and there where we
verify that we are only seeing negative
droplets in the assay this is an example
of the precision testing that we run
here on the y axis you're measuring the
number of t 790 and copies detected in
three different patient samples so these
are clinical samples that had either
high medium or low prevalence of t7 90m
the same sample here is run either on a
single day on three separate plates to
demonstrate intraday reproducibility or
on an inter day study where the
technician runs the same sample on three
separate days and so you can see the the
reproducibility of the assay in this way
additionally to be run larger robustness
studies using our controls
so initially upon launch of the product
we do a 21-day robustness study and here
you can see both the mutant in gray and
also the wild-type signal that we see
over those 21 consecutive days we
continuously track this positive control
and on the right side you can see in
more on extensive measurement looking at
122 days of this QC metric we've
established QC limits specifically 3
standard deviations around the mean that
was that were set on a sample set of 40
days and this QC limit helps us
continuously track to make sure that the
active a is under control or in control
and is not outside of our our
specifications in terms of clinical
validation we are 47 90 M were able to
test 55 samples a mix of positives and
negatives we ran these samples in our
lab following our finalized SOPs for the
Jenna strategy GFR tests including t7 90
M as well as l85a2 R until 19 and I've
note the CT 7-9 am
negative samples were a pre selected
based on their chaos positive status
this is an example of one of the
positive reference samples that we also
found positive in our EGFR t7 90 M
clinical validation study and you can
see again the the blue droplets indicate
that that variant was positive on the
left side of your screen and in addition
I'm showing you an example of a variant
negative result where you see no blue
droplets meaning no t7 90 M positivity
however in this negative sample you can
see there is a robust amount of
wild-type EGFR which we use as an
internal control to verify that we had
sufficient presence of DNA to to get the
result here's a summary of the EGFR t7
90 and performance status following
validation
so we have a ship stability of up to
seven days and an analytic sensitivity
at point zero two percent
we ran fifty five samples in our
clinical validation and identified with
specificity of 100 percent and a seven
society of eighty six point seven
percent more broadly than EGFR t79 TM we
do these studies with all of the
variants that we can find clinical
samples to do and so here you can see
for EGFR sensitizing mutations as well
as email or Al and K wrasse the
sensitivity and specificity numbers
finally I wanted to share with you of
this example from a on market study that
was run using AstraZeneca samples and
they presented this work at ASCO this
past year and they are starting to
explore the idea of using a test like
janus track to measure EGFR clearance
for monitoring purposes and so here the
investigator looked two at three weeks
and six weeks post treatment and defined
patients as either still containing EGFR
signal by one of the three EGFR tests I
mentioned earlier or if they had fully
cleared that signal and what they found
was that prevention progression-free
survival it was significantly better in
those patients that had cleared EGFR
than those that had not and they saw
this effect not only at three weeks but
even more dramatically at six weeks post
treatment so this is an example of how
you know the the use of a blood based
test for monitoring can really
potentially help in the future and
different types of utilities so
additional things that bio Disick's is
doing kind of looking to the future is
developing more tasks using this
sensitive approach so another very
prevalent and interesting biomarker as
you may know is the PDL one
and so a bio Disick's we are looking to
develop a blood based PDL one test
currently the gold standard test is at
issue based IHC and one of them the
preferable markers is using the deco 22
c 3 antibody or the Ventana SP 2 6-3
antibody and so essentially what we're
doing is looking at whether or not we
can generate data that demonstrates
concordance between our PDL 1 based
measurement using DD PCR and the current
gold standard IHC methods and so in the
bottom here you can see some results
from the DD PCR assay i'm the lie axis
you're seeing a total PDL one copies
that we could detect you can see that we
have a nice dynamic range of detection
of PDL 1 and specifically we see high
PDL 1 expression in chaos mutation
positive samples which is in a line with
the literature and the next steps are
essentially to demonstrate concordance
between what is a high express or in
tissue using the IHC test and our blood
based version of the test finally i
wanted to review some of the main points
that we discussed today specifically
droplet digital PCR technology it's
clearly clinically relevant and
especially useful in blood like blood
based assays where you're looking for
very low ly prevalent tumour signals in
the background a lot of bio type signal
and we are using it both to look for
tumor associated DNA and RNA analytes we
we talked a lot about the relationship
between using DD PCR specifically in
oncology and how the community
oncologists and their practices have
really been receptive to this technique
especially because of the great
turnaround times that we can generate
using a DD PCR based approach and so in
the future we're continuing to enhance
the assays to be able to add more
content as we learn more about the
important variants and then SCLC we will
continue to in
our DD PCR based assays including
multiplexing even more variants to
continue to be able to provide that
critical information to the physicians
and with that I think that I will go to
my acknowledgments slide obviously it's
a team effort to do this both bioethics
team as well as the team at bio-rad
which has really supported us in
developing these assays and our other
partners so thank you very much for your
time and I will take questions at this
point
thank you dr. Hestia Mellor for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button well answer as many of your
questions since no time for let's get
started our first question is what is
the benefit of GDP TR compared to other
technologies such as NGS
thank you for that question
so the benefits of DD PCR compared to
other technologies such as NGS are
essentially the very fast turnaround
time and the sensitivity that we are
able to to gain using these techniques
so NGS although it's very broad often
gives information that might not be as
relevant to the physician and to obtain
that more information the technology is
actually a little bit longer to perform
and so by using DD PCR you get targeted
information that is useful to the
physician in a short turnaround time
thank you for that answer our next
question is why are the fusion variants
in the text measured using RNA and not
DNA so there are some variants that are
run using DNA so those include variants
that are you know small in Dells for
example for point mutations so things
like EGFR and chaos and b-raf are
minimal to DNA based testing some other
important drivers and NSEL C are
actually more gross rearrangements and
that's the case for EMF or alpha and
ross one in those cases it can be very
difficult and kind of expensive and
time-consuming to try to measure all of
the different changes that would happen
on the DNA so instead of looking at the
DNA you look at the messenger RNA that
results from that rearrangement and you
can get a lot more information in a test
that is more confined and can be
resulted quickly
our next question is can the process be
automated
thank you yes absolutely the process can
be automated there are a couple of
different solutions for automation
throughout the workflow including during
extraction of the RNA and DNA as well as
during DD PCR so the first step in the
IDI PCR is to generate an emulsion
before you do the amplification and you
can also automate that part of the DD
PCR press process using the auto droplet
generator our last question is what QC
do you use that is a very important
question to maintain quality of these
types of tests so we have a few
different QC metrics that we watch very
closely the first one is something I
talked briefly about in one of the
previous slides this is an internal QC
metric where we look at the amount of
wild type or control gene which were the
green droplets in those TV plots and we
verify that we have enough quality RNA
or DNA that was amplified to be able to
confidently call a result in addition to
that internal QC metric we're also
looking on a batch level at a positive
and negative control to verify that we
are able to detect each variant that we
are looking for in our clinical samples
as well as we don't have any
contaminants that might cause us to
generate false positive results by using
the no template control or the negative
control
I would like to once again thank dr.
heftier Miller for her presentation I'd
also like to thank lab groups for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for online viewing the February of 2018
you'll receive an email from labret
letting you know when this webcast will
be available to rebut please share that
announcements with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye